The subject of hybrid mana has been
pretty front and center recently in EDH
discourse, and I honestly find it a bit
tiresome as a topic. So, this video
won't be about the merits of the
proposed hybrid mana change. Not
exactly, anyway. If you want a video
that covers the meat of the issue, I'll
be linking a Moldtown video on the
subject that I quite liked. But now that
the dust has settled a bit and the most
sharpedged of hybrid gladiators have
doled their role a bit, I want to talk
about the conversation around it and
what it means for us. I will only be
discussing the hybrid mana change in so
far as is necessary to make a case that
the stakes here are low and that the
reaction to the suggestion has been
quite a notable and anomalous event.
Because regardless of whether the change
itself ends up happening, this clearly
has been an event for the online EDH
community. For any of you blissfully out
of the loop, a couple weeks back, Gavin
Ver of Wizards of the Coast made a set
of announcements both in live stream
form and in post form. A [snorts] lot of
it was pretty reasonable tweaks to the
bracket system. those being some
clarification of the language of
different brackets and the moving of a
handful of cards off the game changanger
list. The more controversial part of the
announcement was the potential future
changes part where Gavin discussed the
potential future banning of wristic
study and the possible tweak of allowing
hybrid mana symbols to be considered
either of their colors for the sake of
color identity. The conversation that
has spawned forth about hybrid mana has
kind of fascinated me in the past couple
weeks, mainly because of how
unexpectedly strong and unexpectedly
plentiful the opinions have been,
particularly opinions from the
anti-hybrid mana side. There was an
initial wave of anti-hybrid YouTube
videos, and all videos about the subject
have seen massive numbers of comments
with a lot of people making a heated
case for their side in this debate. This
has been fascinating to me because the
hybrid mana change seems like such a low
stakes issue no matter what side you
fall on. But the community response to
the suggested change has felt like what
it would be if Wizards of the Coast was
suggesting literally abolishing color
identity. So I want to dig a bit into
why that is. What caused this? And to
start, let's talk about literally
abolishing color identity. Kind of. In
an episode of the Magic Mirror podcast
released in March, I gave a sort of
devil's advocate case for why color
identity should be abolished. And here
are a couple key points from that. One,
Magic the Gathering is a game based
around mana and colors with card designs
existing around the fact that colors are
malleable and decks can venture between
colors at the cost of deck space and
deck consistency. There are a lot of
designs that color identity renders
clunky, awkward, and nonsensical, and
this restricts players who wish to play
them. Two, advocates of color identity
will argue that limitations are good for
decks, but color identity doesn't
achieve this in a way that is consistent
or fair. Somebody can play a fivecolor
commander and avoid this restriction
entirely. Whereas somebody who enjoys a
specific monocolor commander that wants
extra support from other colors gets
unfairly limited. Commander is also a
casual format about expression where
players can always choose their own
limitations if they want them. And the
format imposing limitations on its own
goes against this spirit a bit. I think
these arguments are interesting and they
make me curious what a world without
color identity would look like. Despite
this, in that podcast, I mentioned that
I ultimately don't support the abolition
of color identity at this point,
preferring instead a set of changes that
fix two cases where color identity feels
particularly unintuitive to me. Those
being cards whose identity is defined by
indicators rather than symbols and
hybrid mana. This is more or less still
the position I hold at this point, 8
months later. Color identity should
stay, but fixing up these weird side
cases would be neat and probably good
for the format in the long term. You can
agree with that or not, and I'm not here
to convince you about it either way
because this isn't a video about hybrid
mana. Given that, you may be wondering
why I'm even bringing this up. And
that's because the comments on that
video basically agree with me. And
that's interesting, right? In the
context of hearing a devil's advocate
argument against color identity and then
being presented with these softer
changes, people went, "Oh yeah, I like
color identity, but those changes make
sense." Am I some kind of god of
rhetoric fooling innocent commander
players into supporting a hybrid mana
change by positioning it as the
reasonable centrist position in the
color identity debate? Maybe. But
regardless of framing, I have to wonder
what other elements contributed to this
shift. The timing, the atmosphere within
the EDH community, the party making the
suggestion. I don't know the exact
split, but my best guess is that it's
probably a mix of these things. And I'm
going to go through these now. Firstly,
the timing. One version of this idea is
that players dislike this change
happening amidst hybrid mana being more
heavily printed both in recent sets and
in the upcoming set Lurin Eclipse. I
don't think this is a major factor or at
least I hope it isn't because it would
be a very silly thing to be a major
factor. Of course, Wizards of the Coast
is going to suggest changes to the
commander format. At times it feels most
salient to do so based on what is being
printed currently. In fact, it would be
a lot weirder if they made the hybrid
mana change during a period where very
little hybrid mana was getting printed.
Just so I don't leave it unsaid, this is
a minor change and isn't going to
meaningfully increase sales of Lurwin
Eclipse, and Wizards of the Coast knows
that. No, the bigger factor here is what
has happened in the recent past. We just
came out of a summer that saw a lot of
dissatisfaction from the community with
the Spider-Man set being both an
aesthetically jarring Universes Beyond
set and a poor quality set in its own
right. This was paired with an
announcement that next year we'll
feature four different Standard Legal
Universes Beyond sets out of a dizzying
total of seven sets. I don't think I
have the same emotional reaction to this
as a lot of people, but it's certainly a
bummer. I don't like the Spider-Man set,
and I don't like being overwhelmed with
endless standard legal universes beyond
sets. All of this to say, there has been
a lot to be frustrated about, and the
online magic community has been
hotboxing anger and resentment in all of
its various spaces and subspaces and
niches for the past several months. With
the Spider-Man set being past us now,
that anger has been looking for a new
target to explode out at. And this
month, that something ended up being a
suggested hybrid mana change. This
timing factor pairs with the who of the
announcement. The fact that it was
Wizards of the Coast making an
announcement suggesting this change
rather than a handsome and bigrained
YouTuber talking about it in a podcast
definitely had an effect because Wizards
of the Coast is in a rough spot right
now with community trust. I don't know
who exactly to pin the blame on for
every decision, but the collective
decision-making power at Wizards of the
Coast and its parent company Hasbro has
been making a lot of pretty
short-sighted choices, choices that they
probably know will bother the player
base. This is not to say that it's been
all bad for EDH. The bracket system
rollout has been going pretty smoothly,
IMHO, and the general quality of
products aimed at the Commander format
has been pretty decent lately. But
that's arguably part of the problem. The
commander format has been identified as
a cash cow. And a whole lot of decision
about what gets printed, when it gets
printed, and how it gets printed seem to
be motivated by milking that cash cow.
So, it's in this context that the
suggestion of a decision that could be
made about the commander format garers a
massive wave of backlash getting lumped
in with all the other decisions that
have been made in recent years. So, is
this a defense of the hybrid hating
player base? On some level, it
absolutely is in the sense that I think
much of the current climate that
produced this is directly due to
decisions made by Watsi and or Hasbro.
But are people justified in being this
angry about the change? I would say no.
A lot of the arguments against hybrid
mana are reheated versions of the
arguments defending color identity I've
heard. Limitations are good.
Homogenization is bad. Designer intent
doesn't matter. Commander format
architect intentions do matter. And so
on as arguments in favor of color
identity, these are certainly valid.
though a mixed bag in terms of how
persuasive I find each of them
personally. Dredged up and put in this
new context though, they look very
strange because the stakes are so much
lower. It's like rhetorical homeopathy.
The angle you're arguing is very minor,
almost inconsequential, and when you
argue it with the passion of somebody
whose mother just got insulted, it makes
you look like a goofball. Like, take the
question, does hybrid mana weaken color
identity? My answer would be only a tiny
bit at most, particularly if Wizards of
the Coast is more careful with the
hybrid color pie in the future, which I
kind of assume they will be for reasons
I'm throwing on screen, but will not
pause to elaborate on, then that tiny
bit needs to get sifted through the
secondary question of how much does
color identity erosion harm the
commander format. Even if you think the
erosion of color identity is pretty
harmful to Commander, which is a
reasonable thing to believe, you need to
remember that you are not talking about
the abolition of color identity. you are
talking about a niche change to a very
specific set of cards that already have
valid arguments to exist within the
current logic of color identity. I think
a lot of players forget that and just
pretend they're arguing against the
abolishing of color identity and the
result is that conversations end up
feeling deeply strange. Or take the idea
that an expansion of hybrid mana will
allow for the printing of more widely
available broken stuff in the future.
The video from Tor over at MTG Goldfish
is the best articulation of this
argument I've seen. And there is a small
part of me that worries what will happen
when we get a Captain America's Wrath
next year in Hybrid Red White that's
broken and $120 and desired by every red
or white deck. That could happen. But to
contextualize how problematic that is,
let's go through the steps of that
argument. First of all, how problematic
is it if broadly available powerful
cards are printed? Well, it's something
that has more or less always happened
throughout Magic the Gathering's
history, but I guess we can say that
it's less ideal in the case of something
like the one ring that is colorless and
also has impacts on other formats. Step
two of this point is how much does
hybrid mana actually impact this? And
the answer is that I don't see a whole
lot of evidence that this change will
lead to a surge in that. Wizards of the
Coast already has colorless cards they
can use to give a power card to any
commander deck. So, the best tool for
this is already available. In addition,
if we look at the current hybrid mana
cards affected by this change, none are
staples in their two-color identities.
The top two are coldeyed Selki and
Sahili Sublime Artificer. Not exactly
terrifying must plays. Will Wizards of
the Coast start rubbing their hands
together evily and sending hybrid
stockup or hybrid beast whisperer to the
printers the second the hybrid mana
change happens? Maybe, but probably not.
Once again, this is rhetorical
homeopathy. The risks in this particular
case just aren't that high, and players
are using mental stand-ins to make their
arguments rather than discussing the
reality of the situation. To be clear,
it's entirely fair for people to be
against the hybrid mana change for
either of these two reasons. The
direction of the disagreement makes
sense to me, but the scale of the
disagreement looks rather strange, which
is why I think other factors I laid out
earlier are fueling the heat of this
discussion rather than the change
itself. I don't think this change is
very high stakes for those two reasons I
just laid out. And even as Wizards of
the Coast has been making decisions I
dislike, I also don't really buy most
versions of slippery slope arguments
that claim this is just the beginning.
Two little waves over the top of the
conceptual dam that is color identity.
Farexian Mana isn't going to get this
treatment because it's already been
identified by both Wizards of the Coast
and the community as a design outlier.
Offcolor ability cards aren't going to
get added because it'd be simply too
large a change and would require other
format changes to even remotely make
sense. and full-fledged color identity
abolition definitely isn't going to
happen when even an abolition curious
player like myself knows it's a bad
idea. I also think it's important to
remember that this change wasn't
invented by Wizards of the Coast 2
seconds ago. This is something that
players and designers alike have
suggested and made cases for in the
past, including myself several months
ago. Not everything needs to be some
nefarious mination by a corporation, and
to pretend that a hybrid mana change is
a brand new thing asked for by no
players is just plainly dishonest. At
the end of the day, I still understand
why people tar the decision makers at
Wizards of the Coast as greedy and
corporate and nefarious and other such
poratives. It seems like this year has
really been an inflection point around
Universes Beyond due to it suddenly
making up a large portion of standard
sets. The result is that even many
players who were relatively neutral
about it in previous years, such as
myself, have started to sour on it
pretty heavily, and the people who are
already against it are finding
themselves waiting into deeper and
deeper levels of dissatisfaction. The
current trajectory of the game is not a
good one, and there is reason to be
unhappy. That said, I also hope that we
as a player base can get better at
calibrating the temperature of our
discussions. When we respond with
disproportionate levels of anger and
gloom to lower stakes suggestions, I
worry that it weakens our ability to be
taken seriously on the things that
matter more, and it also distracts from
those more important things. There are
real decisions being made that have the
potential to seriously impact the future
trajectory of the game. And the impacts
of the hybrid mana suggestion are
microscopic compared to the addition of
even a single extra standard legal
universes beyond set. I also think it's
better for the health of the community
to not blow every announcement and
update way out of proportion. When I see
comments declaring every tiny thing as
the death of the game, it makes me think
of the vast array of spaces across the
internet where people marinate in
collective despair and pull themselves
deeper and deeper into conspiracy and
dumerism. It's [snorts] not that much of
a problem just yet, but that's just
something I've been getting little
whiffs of this year, and it's not
healthy. Maybe it's because I've been
involved in a wide range of game
communities from flourishing to actively
dying. But my general reaction to a game
company doing stuff I dislike is to
either distance myself from it or take
some control into my own hands. The
first is absolutely helpful sometimes,
and I fully believe there are people
discontentedly sticking around with
magic who probably need to move on to
other things. But I'm going to focus on
the second. If what Wizards of the Coast
is handing you doesn't satisfy your
needs, build something for yourself. A
format, a sub format, a cube, a
community, a different game, or just a
play group of people looking for the
same sort of fun as you are. The best
antidote to feeling disempowered and
dissatisfied by the decisions of others
is to take back control of your own
enjoyment. That's undoubtedly harder
than just accepting what a game company
is actively handing you, but the
potential benefits are well worth the
effort. Thanks for watching, and thanks
to Architect for supporting the channel.
I've been working to finish my fall
supporter deck review, and it makes life
so much easier when I can port
somebody's deck into Architect, do all
the necessary categorization and
analysis to get an idea of what's going
on, and then have the inebite categories
look nice enough for me to be happy just
throwing them into a video as a visual.
I've also been brewing a couple new
decks lately, and if you want to check
those out, a link to my decks is in the
description. I also want to thank my
patrons for their ongoing support of
everything I do here. I had some stuff
to say about the nature of design intent
that didn't feel quite at home in this
video. So, I threw those thoughts in
their own separate video for supporters.
If that's something you want to hear me
talk about, you can become a YouTube
member or a patron today.